welcome back to safety blitz starting
two-time super bowl champ rodney
harrison jack collins with call this
third in short three rapid fire
questions we'll get straight into number
one a single word one word to describe
coach gase with the jets his tenure with
the jets how was
i would say waste
waste it
i think a waste is pretty good why waste
because it's just like he weighs they
wasted time like no one thought that
adam gates was the right guy for the
jets job like everybody was stunned like
why are they hiring him you see what he
just did in in miami so i thought it was
a waste of time because now they're back
in the same situation that they're in
now they can't find anyone to develop
sam darnold
yeah i was between mistake disaster you
name it even from the opening press
conference something looked like it was
something looked like it was up it just
something looked very off about the
whole situation it has played out just
like that since you almost hope that sam
darnold's career doesn't get caught in
the whitewash here and he's done too but
there's probably some possibility of
that as well our second question the
best fit to coach the jacksonville jags
who would that be
assuming for the sake of this argument
that they would have trevor lawrence as
well
oh definitely i would say eric bienemy
is a guy you saw the work that he did
with patrick mahomes in the background
out there in kansas city and and this is
a guy that i played with he's a good
person he works extremely hard he's
extremely passionate and you know andy
reid is a very meticulous guy he's not
going to have eric b enemy as his
offensive coordinator if this guy wasn't
sharp if he wasn't bright and if he
wasn't on time so
i like eric manami and i think he should
get a legitimate chance i know they're
talking about um what's urban meyer he
hasn't
[Music]
come on man urban meyer and or eric
manami a guy that helped
develop patrick mahomes it's not even
close it's not i'm giving this young and
you got to understand too eric man and
me
how old is urban meyer 56
maybe right around there six years old
yeah something like that but i think you
know eric ben and me he's been around a
lot of these young guys he knows how to
develop and i just think that he would
be a great fit for the jacksonville
jaguars we'll see
i think the enemy's number one too he's
going to be up for a handful of these
jobs you have to anticipate that houston
probably will want him to come in and
coach watson the jets may want him
become coach darnold or whoever else
they may go draft i think he's going to
be candidate number one for a whole
bunch of these jobs
if they can't get the enemy
maybe joe brady would be an interesting
guy to bring in there the success that
he had with joe burrow kind of young on
young if you will i think he'd be able
to have that same kind of success with
trevor lawrence assuming that is who
they end up going with brian dable is
another one if they can't get the enemy
dabel going there he just showed you
what he could do year one two and three
with josh allen it would be pretty
interesting to see him go down there
with the jags too for urban buyers
purposes
there's such a difference between being
a great recruiter and being a great nfl
coach where you just got to be able to
win these one possession games i don't
know that urban meyer's skill set would
translate perfectly apples to apples to
the nfl like people are thinking am i
crazy for thinking that i mean it seems
like nfl coach and college coach two
totally different things to me
absolutely not i mean you're dealing
with college guy kids that you know
they're looking for for pell grants and
things like that you're looking you know
you're looking at national football
league these guys are making millions
they're looking at you like man i make
more money than you what are you talking
about so yeah you're spot on with that
all right cool number three the biggest
disappointment it's an interesting one
the biggest disappointment of this nfl
season now that were through week 17 was
what
i would probably say the raiders
at one point the raiders were six and
three they had beat the chiefs they beat
the saints and um they beat the browns
and you know carr was playing
outstanding everybody said he was a top
10 quarterback and then all of a sudden
that loss to the chiefs on sunday night
football everything spiraled down they
fell apart and then second straight year
they just failed to make the playoffs
that's a good one that's tough to
compete with the chargers probably high
on a lot of people's lists too philly
another one that's got to be high on
people's list with what what happened
maybe people were so high on the wentz
wince falls apart dallas after what
happened the dak prescott that one
probably gets a pass san francisco
probably gets a bit of a pass based on
what's happened via injuries atlanta i
mean that's that's really falling apart
in a big big way houston even with
watson and you know getting rid of their
coach throughout the course of the year
that's a tough year and the other one
that i probably finished with too
new england the patriots how high would
new england be on your disappointed list
this year
well just i would be more disappointed
that they didn't go out and get enough
talent you know and i was more
disappointed with cam newton in anything
because i i was really one of those guys
that came out and get cam newton signed
cam newton he's hungry he's going to do
the right thing he's going to show your
level of maturity and then all of a
sudden you know he had that big game
against cam um seattle
and all of a sudden he he forgot how to
throw the football and then when you see
him throwing he's far off he's throwing
the ball into the ground and then all of
a sudden you get to a point
week 17 and you just say you know what
the patriots need a new quarterback
because cam he can't play he can't throw
the football so
yeah pretty high there we go jack
i think he's pretty high on the
disappointing list there too we'll see
what happens with cam that's that's one
of the more up in the air futures i mean
is it up in the air future before you
think he starts again you think he
starts again
i'm going to say not next year unless
somebody gets hurt where he would go
into the game because i you know it was
a toss-up whether or not he was going to
get a starting job prior to this year it
took new england being the last team
willing to give him a chance and
basically did so for no money and that
didn't work out typically that
translates into a backup job after all
of that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports